luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and i've got an awesome
blacksmithing project here for you today
i'm going ice fishing up in alaska and i
need an ice fishing chisel to cut a hole
in the ice
so i've got a design up in my head a
little something special that you might
not have seen before
and we are going to make it right here
on the forge but not only that
i'm going to bring you guys along with
me up to alaska and we're going to see
how it works
go gather some sticks and help me start
the forge
yeah go get some sticks
so
so
[Music]
hahaha
[Music]
[Music]
so
i need to make the neck a little bit
thinner
[Music]
so
well i've got the sharp end of the ice
chisel done now i'm gonna make the back
end and i've got a piece of plain old
weldable bar
stock here
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
well i'm done with the forging part you
can see what i've done is i've forged a
chisel side
and a scoop side that'll both go on
opposite ends
of a pole and this you'll be used to
chisel the hole and then scoop the snow
out with the other end and i've dipped
both parts in peanut oil and put them on
the forge
and let that peanut oil bake off so that
it gets covered
in kind of a residue that'll make it a
little bit more waterproof think of it
as kind of like seasoning cast iron same
sort of principle all right now we're
going to sharpen our chisel on my very
crowded workbench here
[Music]
all right now i got to pack these things
up take them to alaska because we're
going to do some ice fishing
all right here i am in anchorage alaska
at my father's workshop and i've got
both ends of my ice fishing chisel
and i've got a broom handle here
there we go we got a chisel on one end
and a scoop on the other
so you can cut your hole and scoop it
out without bending over
i think we need to take this thing ice
fishing
hey once i really had
you try to make a circular hole because
that's what we used to but a square hole
is more effective
with the chisel
little wussy ones you're gonna go nice
i see how this is
what do you think of the chisel it's the
best one i've ever used
that went through that in a couple
minutes it changes
yeah very sharp chisel edge the scoop's
nice
worked out well yeah
[Music]
but it's pretty it's really pretty
you want me to there we go
you bouncing on the bottom now oh
another one
oh it's a different one definitely there
we
there go go well guys i'm pretty pleased
with how this turned out man
cuts through the ice like butter and uh
having the scoop on the end so you don't
have to bend over to get the
chunks and shavings out of the hole it's
pretty awesome i like it
it's light it's sharp works pretty good
if you guys like this sort of thing i've
got an entire playlist of all my
blacksmithing and foraging videos
so i'll put a link in the description of
that and don't forget to click subscribe
to the outdoor boys youtube
channel we put on new videos every
saturday morning
see you then if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching